every time that I'm out there there's a
green arrow
I'm targeting of the threats that are
out there and the threats that are
undoubtedly coming Star City needs the
green arrow
you and I walk between two walls being a
man
people need you to be but for the father
that your son made you to be but we can
only do that for so long
it's just a dream that lands here where
do you think the bad man is
kissee does not bend to terrorism
there's a million psychos
always trying to change
arrow season premiere Thursday October
12 at 9/8 central on the CW
hey everybody new arrow trailer I'm
gonna call this the Deathstroke school
of parenting so let's break this down
and there will be new giveaway stuff at
the end of the video but if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe make sure you click that Bell
so you don't miss any of the videos that
are coming up because this is premiering
in a couple weeks it'll be on Thursday
night just like they say in the trailer
so if you didn't know arrow is now a
Thursday night show at 9 p.m. instead of
8 p.m. on Wednesdays but the whole thing
about this trailer is the message the
Deathstroke is giving Oliver is that we
live in two worlds you can only walk in
both for so long in the ideas is that
now he has William with him so we'll
talk about who I think is dead in a
second I think that pretty much tells
you one of the big people that died on
the island if William is spending so
much time with Oliver in present day but
now Oliver has to be the father but he
says Star City needs the green arrow
so Deathstroke is just telling him that
you can't do the fun nighttime stuff and
be the awesome dad at the same time and
obviously we know that things didn't go
so well for Deathstroke because he was
stuck on the island for a while he
didn't even know if his family was alive
Oliver had to talk him into it when he
was going into the mirakuru madness
remember your son Joseph remember who
you are
shado something you deserve to know
she's lousy asleep maybe not the way
that you wanted her to she loved you so
they say that one of the big themes of
arrow season six is family in Oliver is
going to have to find a way to be the
green arrow and be the dad to William at
the same time so I think that's sort of
his arc across the season is like how do
you do both of those things at the same
time without being really shitty at one
of them so I do kind of wonder how many
episodes Williams going to be in but it
looks like we have race' the maid from
Season one who's back she I think she
was only in the pilot actually but she's
back at she'll probably help take care
of William while Oliver is off doing the
nighttime stuff for being mayor during
the day but I think that's a bit of a
hat tip to that being Samantha being one
of the people that died on the island
you see her run off at the end of last
season thinking that Williams somewhere
I need to find him Felicity chases after
her so he looks like he's been crying
his eyes out here in this scene so
clearly he lost somebody that he loves a
lot so of all the people that I think
that are outright dead I think that's
just a hat tip for Samantha I think
something could happen to Thea too but
the whole idea with her is that Merlyn
sacrificed himself and he's supposed to
be dead and it will inform her arc in
season six like oh my god the guy that I
hated that I thought was a villain
killed himself so that I could live how
do I deal with that what kind of awful
twist would that be if he did that and
then five minutes later she winds up
dying herself - in an explosion so I
think Thea is going to be fine
regardless of how many episodes she's
going to be in but they do make it seem
like in the interim time between this
explosion and them making it back to
Star City that they've been recuperating
they've been dealing with the grief of
the things that they've lost and
everything that's happened like it was
just such an intense encounter for them
that they have to deal with it for a
couple months but like Oliver says in
this trailer look the city needs the
Green Arrow I need to put the hood back
on again and then he starts running into
the Bratva you get into all this black
siren stuff so let me know in the
comments who do you think died on the
island and do you think that it was more
than one person because I feel like they
could just kill some
antha and that would feel really
hardcore like oh my god now Williams
gonna be living with all of her
full-time how is he gonna deal with that
what kind of dad is he going to be is he
gonna be like Deathstroke be a shitty
dad and have his son wind up being some
terrible killer when he grows up which a
lot of you have already started to guess
that maybe vigilante is actually Joseph
Wilson Slade's son and that's sort of
the message of season six like your
shitty dad your kid is gonna wind up
making all the same mistakes that you
made so no confirmation on who vigilante
is but it seems like it just plays into
the idea of Slade being a really crappy
dad and that serving is an example to
Oliver of what not to do like okay I'm
not going to pay attention to the
Deathstroke school of parenting like
everything that he's telling him in this
trailer is like look kid do not be like
I was but also like the couple of the
villains that you see pop up in here I
think one are part of who's going to
become Richard dragons crew like black
siren here then you also have the
brought bug you have Anatole who's going
to come back and be an antagonist but if
you're wondering why the arrow cave is
exploding here that's just black siren
from later in the trailer taking a hit
out she's probably trying to steal
something from them or take them down so
whatever it is she's after she's after
it in the first couple of episodes I
don't know if all this footage is from
the first episode is probably from the
first two maybe three episodes but if
you haven't been watching Stephen Amell
on social the last couple days he's been
posting pictures from the four night
crossover they've been filming that
while they're also filming the regular
episodes of the TV shows so he's been
shooting arrow episode 7 while he's been
shooting crossover episodes and they
just bounce back and forth between the
sets crossovers day 8
it's late but it's it's also early
ready anytime
they tend to shoot things out of order
and it still be super spoilery so I
think he's actually wearing his new
costume in this picture here but they
shoot all kinds of different scenes so
remember they're playing different roles
so you'll see him wearing his green
arrow costume when he post pics from
behind the scenes and you'll also
probably see him all covered up like
trying to hide what he's wearing just
because they're not ready to show
everything off yet and because this year
everybody is sort of playing a
doppelganger of themselves which is
gonna be fantastic the big reveal is
what those costumes look like so treat
this comic book cover like concept art
it'll look a little bit different in the
light of day but it'll be really cool so
I think what they'll do is they they
might release pictures before they
actually release the trailer for the
crossover and I don't think we're gonna
see any footage from that for at least
another four or five weeks like the end
of October beginning of November because
the crossover itself isn't happening
till the end of November but I've
already done a separate video about like
all the crossover the earth X stuff so
I'll post a link to that at the end of
this and I also have a new flash video
that'll be coming up in the next day or
two so there is a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video congratulations to
the winner from my last video
Arctic Mule please private message me so
I can get your contact details I'll just
name a new winner when I post that new
flash video so whole bunch of stuff
coming up while you wait for it you can
click here for brand new flash crossover
and you can click here for brand new
Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight